we're gonna review this week's power
rankings mini shake up
at the top and also we're gonna get your
feedback and answer your questions
and there are my power rankings chris
you're quick to point out don't blame
you
blame me that's right if people don't
like them but folks in buffalo
should have no complaints because the
buffalo bills
have now made it by virtue of their
victories over the past two weeks over
the 49ers and the steelers
all the way to number two
welcome back to the nfl's wait for it
upper echelons buffalo bills
seriously well they're there you know i
mean
first off like with the bill's
conversation i know for both of us
it's gone from the last few weeks of hey
they're a playoff team
to now whoa it looks like they could be
a legit super bowl contender so that's
that they've changed their view
uh or at least in my eyes they have and
i think a lot of people certainly
now like with that two-three combination
right there how close was that
like you know i wonder what vegas would
do in a bill's packer super bowl i would
think the packers would be favored by a
few
but you know how much did you have to
nitpick over those two
full transparency i was upset with the
packers because they didn't cover on
sunday against the lions which was
one of our best bets so they're not
going to be number two unless they can
beat the lions by more than the
appointed spread
they didn't have as good of a game as we
thought they were going to have against
a team they should have
manhandled so that's why i went with the
bills
at number two and also the bills were
already ahead of the pack you got to do
something
significant relative to the other team
to jump them
they didn't play this year they could
play as you said in the super bowl but
that that was simple for me bills were
more impressive in their win
than the packers were bills were already
ahead of green bay so they go to two
packers go to three
yesterday aaron rodgers told pat mcafee
that the pack i know great football i
know
now and the pack look hey i still
worry packers fans as should you
about one of these games where after the
fact aaron rodgers is saying we didn't
have much energy today and i don't know
why because
that seems to be looming right around
the corner especially when things are
going well
like right now like is it coming right
now
when you have the one seed and all you
have to do is win your last three games
are you about to step in that low energy
pothole
that's what i worry about for the
packers over the balance of the regular
season and into the playoffs chris yeah
i understand that well i mean we saw
them kind of slip up against you know
your minnesota vikings at home
definitely we saw them kind of fall
asleep at the wheel when they had a lead
against the indianapolis colts those are
their last two losses um you know
they're they're an interesting team i
hear you i don't know
i mean it's all about the offense the
efficiency rogers they're in a great
place so therefore
you know when he talks to pat mcafee and
all those type of things he's feeling
good
because they're one of the best offenses
in football points yards they can do it
all
you know i still question that defense
it'd actually be a cool super bowl to
see bill's packers and everything there
but with the nfc right now and you know
again i don't know if there's
you know there's no great great team in
the nfc
with aaron rodgers at home you know in
wisconsin
green bay there and hey it's it's 12
degrees and it's divisional sunday and
now it's championship sunday and it's 10
degrees
that that's that's the biggest home
field advantage to me
uh that i can really look at right now
in the nfc playoffs this year without no
fans and things like that and that's
where
they can be dangerous and you're right
they got a chance here to hold on to it
let's see if they can do that they got
one legit test left with that tennessee
titans game
number one seed back in 2011 and your
new york giants went there and put the
hurt on the green bay packers with fans
president can remember watching it
that propensity has been there for the
packers over the past decade one of the
reasons why they've
only won one super bowl with aaron
rodgers so whether they get the one seat
or not
i just worry about that one day for
three hours in january where
it's just not firing on all cylinders
and again if you're a packers fan you
should worry about it too yeah well mike
even to your point
like think about last year week 17
remember
they were down to the detroit lions and
they had they had to come back and
in a frenzy type comeback to make sure
they could
secure the number two spot so that to
your they had something to play for
there so that to your example we have
seen that before
and uh you know i i don't think you're
crazy to bring that up
questions about the upper ranks of the
power rankings
as relates to the buffalo bills this is
the highest the bills have been
since they were number three before
losing to the tennessee titans in week
five at the time the bills were 4-0
steve ash ash22uk via twitter asks do
you think the bills have what it takes
to beat patrick mahomes chiefs this year
i think this is steve ash speaking that
the chiefs are beatable
with the right team well yeah they are
beatable with the right team but it's
also you got to get them in the right
spot because i feel like if the chiefs
see you coming and are fully prepared
and ready to go
they are almost impossible to beat
because even if you build a lead they're
going to find a way to come back do you
think chris that if the bills and the
chiefs cross paths in the post-season
fully aware of what happened when the
two teams got together in the regular
season and the chiefs kind of smothered
the bills do you think the bills have a
chance to knock them off in january
i do i i do i they would be one of those
teams that i think
could be scary for the kansas city
chiefs right it's not a you know we know
kansas city's defense it's just
nfl average probably a little below that
with that offense and josh allen and
everything like that i think that could
be a scary combination
listen we saw a bad elements you know
pretty close football game earlier this
year 26-17 right chiefs win over the
bills
but to me you know that that we know
what the chiefs are the chiefs are king
of the hill they're the man it's my
homes
i mean it's gonna take something special
to knock them off but i will say
from that little two-game stretch where
the buffalo bills played the tennessee
titans and the kansas city chiefs back
to back
lost those games they've played
phenomenal football ever since
it's like they realized wait this is
what we got to do
if we got to get into the super bowl
conversation i think that was new for
them i think josh allen was nervous on
the stage against patrick mahomes
and the week before in the tennessee
titans game on you know national tv and
all those things
and i think they've realized you know
they've answered that challenge is what
i'm saying and i think they've realized
what it takes maybe to
you know be in that upper echelons hey
oh seattle came to town they're one of
those teams
let's beat them oh the 49ers are getting
hot oh we can't beat them on a monday
night football watch us
you know and then of course the
pittsburgh steelers so i think they're a
totally different team
than earlier this year and now we're in
that like wait
let me stick out my chest we're kind of
good we got some confidence here we're
playing some d and josh allen
has shown he can manage games a little
bit till we that's where buffalo
to me is change and i think that could
be a scary matchup for kansas city
when that time comes i spoke to alan
after they beat the chargers and i said
look you've got
three prime time games coming up you've
got an nfl network saturday game coming
up
is this your opportunity yeah to
basically let
the world know what the bills are and he
downplayed it but you look at how
they've performed
the first half of those games yeah 49ers
against uh
look the 49ers are still the 49ers even
with all the injuries they have kyle
shanahan and both you and i thought the
49ers would win that game the brothers
were impressive then
they were impressive against the
steelers now they go to denver which is
not an easy place to go play and win and
then they have the patriots
on what will be the last monday night
game of the year so this is a great
test run for the builds in big spots
where everyone's watching
and gets them ready for that wild card
game where maybe this time around
they don't blow a big lead they don't
come out sluggishly they just come out
and take it
i still don't know whether that means
they can beat the chiefs chris because
look
all the way back in early september you
were saying chiefs to repeat chiefs to
repeat chiefs to repeat
because there hasn't been a repeat since
the 2003-2004 patriots right
yeah but right now though and i'm
i'm always inclined to take the field
yeah
this year team or the field pick a team
or the field
shereen williams and i were talking
about this last night chiefs of the
field
i'm taking the chiefs right now i'm
taking the chiefs to win it all
chiefs of the field i i'm with you mike
i i
am too in a year where we're like we're
not seeing any real great dominant
defense in the nfl
and yet we know the guy can already and
the offense and the team can already
overcome
great defenses in the nfl like we saw
them do in the super bowl last year
uh i'm i'm i'm with you mike i mean and
just
the confidence in which they play you
know you could take it good or bad
a little bit but you know the the glass
you know half
full look at the kansas city chiefs is
go
they're 12-1 and i'm not sure they've
played an
a-game the whole year as a complete
football team
you know they've had games where special
teams and defense are good and then the
offense wasn't great or
the offense is great and you know the
special teams are good but the defense
falls apart or
or the offense just as sloppy and they
just get it done when they need to
so that's what's scary too mike i mean
they could be one of those teams that
you know all of a sudden the playoffs
come
another level of focus comes and they
bring their level of game to an
area we haven't seen and maybe they just
you know kick the crap out of everybody
in the afc playoffs and end up in the
super bowl and who knows what happens
there but
i'm with you i'm not i'm taking the
chiefs against the field too
one more on the bills the laughing man 5
via twitter says can we
talk more about eric the enemy for head
coach and less about brian dayball
yeah yeah bill's mafia is trying to keep
the team together for at least one more
year that relates to one of my
grievances that we have coming up later
in the hour
but yeah i could look this is always one
of the
problems of being a great team you have
to worry not just about your players
becoming attractive in free agency when
they're able to go get paid you have to
worry about your coaches
being head coaching candidates and
having to backfill and maybe it works
and maybe it doesn't maybe it takes a
couple of years to get a new offensive
coordinator up to speed
i don't know that brian dayball is a
serious candidate it all depends upon
how many jobs are available
and whether to what extent he's
available to be interviewed i continue
to believe that's a major impediment the
rules that the nfl has in place
keeping guys from taking jobs until
their teams are done the far the bills
go and i guess that would be my advice
to the laughing man 5.
root for your team to go as far as
possible because that tends to make it
harder
not always but in some cases to get that
job because there are teams that just
want to get their
position filled all things being equal
they'll take the guy who's available
yeah no i mean you're you're right about
that we've seen it
it kind of hinders the the the coach
that you know makes that deep playoff
run
but i understand our man's fear here and
you know those two names that's that's
where it starts at least for the
offensive guys this year
when you just talk about hey offensive
names
offensive you know coordinators who are
going to be head coaches
guys that could be quarterback
whisperers and understand how to move
the ball a whole
different a lot you know a lot of
different ways man
the enemy and day ball are where it's at
you know and day ball
you know i of course i i was with him in
new england for a little bit
he's got the head coaching mentality you
know i think he's going to be a perfect
fit one day and then how could you not
recognize what he did with josh allen i
mean most people
thought he was not fixable right and
the fact that hey you know one he sees
the talent in them and all that and the
bill's organization did too
but hey they cleaned them up they've
figured out how to
fix his mechanics make things work bring
out his talent to the utmost ability in
which he has
that's worth something too i mean if
yeah be enemy and day ball to me
i i would be really shocked actually if
both of them don't get a job this year i
really would be
on the other side of the top five we've
got the los angeles rams they are at
six the seahawks had eight two teams
from that division
in the top ten the odds right now
courtesy of points
bet has the rams minus 200 to win the
division
the seahawks plus 165. what a difference
from earlier in this year when it looked
like the seahawks were going to run away
with it
who do you like between those two teams
to win the division i'm settling on the
rams even though i've been a seahawks
guy the past few years
it sure feels like the rams have what it
takes to win the division it definitely
does
i mean seattle seen i mean the the rams
seem to be a more
complete football team i guess that's
the phrase i would use
just you know more consistent week to
week on the offensive side of the ball
and then the defense is is special it's
top notch i mean
there's not really anything you could
say negative about that rams defense we
saw what they did to the patriots i know
that's not a great offense but
hey they've already given russell wilson
issues and a lot of other offenses
issues yeah i go with the rams i do you
know you know the big thing with the
rams i mean
i like the football team a hundred
percent you know the big thing is
they're a little bit of a match up
football to me
team to me in the sense of when they
play that wrong match up
and okay like we've talked about nine
zillion times over the last two years
where now the mcveigh trickery you know
and him screwing your defense over
with his little formula plays there
doesn't work you know yeah i do worry
about jared goff
that that's that's really the the first
thing that comes to my mind when you
come to the negatives of
of the rams when they match up against
you know the the upper teams of football
but i still think they're a better team
than seattle
yeah i agree with you right now and the
defense has come along and with cam
akers
getting better and better every week and
the team seeming to build the running
game more and more around him that could
be a key
when you look at the factors we always
talk about for january football running
game and defense running game and
defense running gaming defense who's got
it better than anyone else in the nfc
right now
it's the la rams rams chiefs would not
be a bad
super bowl just a couple of days after
we were reminded of that rams chiefs
game from 2018
when we saw that ravens browns game the
most exciting game since rams chiefs
arguably we could have rams chiefs again
when it's all said and done here's a
question from nfl fan
matt did the cardinals find something on
offense
on sunday against the giants playing
more backyard football between k1 and
deandre hopkins question mark what do
you think of that
well the offense is is not been special
i don't know if they found anything
that i looked at and i got to watch that
that side of the film back a little bit
because i haven't seen that to really
give an
in-depth answer there but they weren't
moving the ball at will or anything like
that against that giants defense you
know it was more or not the
the arizona defense setting up the
cardinals offense
you know the thing that i do like about
the cardos is they can play some ugly
football
it doesn't have to be 400 yards by kyla
murray running and throwing in this
highlight show
you know they've shown the ability to
kind of grind it out
and win games 20-17 and play that style
of football i think that's what's kind
of impressive about them but
no i think their offense is still in the
midst
of trying to figure out a few other
avenues of how to attack
offenses right now you've heard anybody
that's listened to me as tell you it's
become kind of predictable
and i think defenses have figured that
system out to a degree let alone
i think kylo murray is probably a little
banged up too
nfc south a race to the finish line the
colts at number seven the titans at
number
ten man however our friends at
points bet sportsbook have the titans as
the
minus 160 favorite that means is always
got about 160 to win a hundred
the colts plus 130 about 100 win 130. so
the titans favored to win
the division and the upcoming schedules
tennessee
final three weeks they have the lions at
the packers at the texans
the colts have final three weeks the
texans
at the steelers and the jaguars both
teams big tests when
week 16 rolls around who do you lean
toward between tennessee and
indianapolis
well i i like i think tennessee the
football team
better than indianapolis there's a lot
that i like about indianapolis cults and
if they can continue to run the ball
like we saw
last week a little bit it might make me
think differently of them
but you know that the titans offense is
elite there's just no other way to say
that and it's tough to stop
you know of course we know they have an
elite running game and offensive line
and then
you know tannehill and the weapons are
sneaky elite
and what they do in the pass game yeah
it might not be 45 attempts in 400 yards
but it
it you know so many weeks it's 18
completions for
close to 300 yards or it's big plays
when they strike in the passing game um
so i'm a little bit more of a fan of
them right now
plus i'd like to see the colts and
phillip rivers in play off football
first before i give them
give them that ranking over the titans i
mean this five through their six through
ten area
i i i don't know how you feel mike but i
just i look at that and go it almost can
change
weekly right now i mean it really does
it's it's hard to figure
that group of teams out uh you know
i don't think they're perfect they're
kind of a work in progress and they're
kind of all over the place as far as
week-to-week performances
i always say throw out the first couple
of weeks of the season
as it relates to whether or not you
should freak out about your favorite
team or
feel all that good about your favorite
team because things change dramatically
however
those games those outcomes those final
score and what they do in the standings
can resonate
because right now the titans have the
advantage over the colts and the
tiebreaker
for division record because the colts
lost
to the jaguars in week one only one
of the season right for the jacksonville
jaguars
you take that away number one the colts
have a one game lead and then number two
they have a push in that tiebreaker but
right now since they
were one and one in their head-to-head
series it falls to division record and
the titans have that advantage by
one game in the loss column because the
colts
lost to the jaguars and that could be
the thing that keeps the colts from
winning
the division uh let's slide a little
farther down as we try to figure out the
seventh seed in the afc
dolphins at the 11th spot in the power
rankings ravens at 13.
for the seven seed points bet has the
odds at baltimore
minus 9 10. you got to bet 910 bucks to
win
a hundred overwhelming favorite then are
the ravens
to get the seventh seed miami plus 200
the las vegas raiders
plus 350. i'm surprised the ravens are
that strong of a favorite considering
that right now technically they're on
the outside looking in
i know but i think it's got a everything
has to do with the the the dolphins and
their schedule right i mean and just the
way
you know and two quite honestly with tua
yes they've been winning but to me it's
lessened them a little bit as far as a
dangerous
football team is concerned you know i do
because i still think they're
they're still managing him to a degree
they can't just let him go out and just
call any play they want
and i'm not saying that's a negative
that's okay it's you know he's a rookie
quarterback most of them need to be
managed to a degree
um but man that schedule you know to
play the patriots this week we know what
that's going to be i mean of course
that's a personal battle there's a lot
of common knowledge between both sides
there
and you know we know the patriots are
going to have a good game plan and
things but then the week after that the
raiders who will have
you know extra time because they play
this thursday
i think they're a tough matchup for
miami actually in a lot of ways i really
do
and then the buffalo bills to end it you
know the miami
maybe their best scenario is to hope
buffalo has nothing to play for
the last week that might actually help
them get in when all said and done but
if you made me bet money right now mike
i don't know
about you i'd take the ravens too
interesting dynamics are going to come
into play the last week of the season as
well we've seen this before where
there's a team with a higher seed
that would kind of not be all that upset
about losing because they have a better
wild card match up with the lower seat
right
i think back to tony dungy's message
though from 2006
when being the higher seed even though
they didn't get a bye
gave them home field advantage in the
afc championship game you want that
higher spot on the playoff tree if you
just
engage because you never know when it's
going to deliver for you a home game
with everything on the line but this
year the argument is it doesn't matter
there's no home field advantage well
here's where it matters you get to stay
at home
you don't have to travel you don't have
to add that extra stress and strain on
your body and on your mind
to go into a potential coronavirus hot
spot in january you get to stay home
and you get to sleep in your bed most of
the week and you you're just you're
you're comfortable there you're it's
it's
although we'll talk about postseason
bubbles coming up maybe nobody's going
to be sleeping in their bed
voluntarily by the time it comes around
but i still think there's something to
be said
for being as high on that ladder as you
can be and being at home even though
home field advantage chris this year
isn't what it is in any other year no i
i know i mean you're right
but i i think that's the point you're
exactly right though you'd still
doesn't matter traveling as we've talked
about off air before and things like
that
that can still wear you out you know the
fact of hey like
just the oh i gotta get all right
practice i gotta go home i gotta pack
okay i gotta be back at the facility to
get my you know airport screening there
and then do that and get on the bus and
all right now we're in the plane and
it's you know to the hotel it can be a
whirlwind
of a day whirlwind just throw you all
over the world but finally before you
settle into your hotel room
so uh yeah that's still a real aspect
fans are not
mike we're like and one more one more
advantage too let's remember this yeah
we talked about this earlier in the year
as it relates to potential coronavirus
transmission
you want to be in a home team locker
room not so damn happy tiny
small someone's butt is in your face
visiting team locker room
where there's no way you can keep your
distance and that is the day where if
anyone slips through the cracks
shedding virus it may be shed all over
you
that's right and i don't know what butt
to butt transmission's like in a small
locker room so i haven't checked that
science out but i got you you're right i
mean
you're you're definitely right all right
i'm trying to make me funny i'm sorry
all right
all right let me ask you this though tom
brady's couch
if you're a yes if you're the dolphins
and you got
you know miami right all right so let's
just say pittsburgh loses
to the colts in a few weeks right now
now buffalo's the number two seed
right and uh they get to that last week
of the year
you know if they have a plant chance to
where
it's play and maybe knock the dolphins
out
or rest up and get ready for the wild
card game and then you have to see maybe
the dolphins the next week too which one
would you do there
i just think that this year
i i'm just i want to play to win i just
think that there's something to be said
for playing to win
and not try to get too cute and not try
to engineer who you're going to play
especially in the afc i think all those
teams are dangerous i know
the idea of laying down and losing to
the dolphins
and then playing the dolphins the next
week i i don't like that
i know i don't like that do you like
playing the dolphins beating them and
then having to have the ravens come to
town the next week either that's that's
why i kind of brought it up because it's
well well yeah i mean but that's a tough
one that's why i brought it up
it's yeah i i understand what you're
saying i still
i i ultimately want to have confidence
in my team i agree
and we will take on anyone i think that
mindset is more
valuable than the strategic effort to
try to get a better match up although as
you say all the time it's a matchup
driven league and maybe you can succeed
right into a matchup that is going to
get you knocked out
i just i think that the that that that
that suit of mental armor that is
we will take on anyone and we will beat
anyone
i think that's where the value is going
into this playoffs especially because at
some point
you're gonna cross paths with the kansas
city chiefs you don't want to have
anything other than this
heir of we'll take on anyone because at
some point we may have to take on the
best team in the league
yeah i agree with you there and i'm i'm
with you too i mean you know
play football you know try to be at your
best
you know and if it gets to that week 17
matchup if you want to take your guys
out in the fourth quarter or whatever i
mean you always have that
option to do that type of stuff but you
know i
i would probably take your your route
too if i had to play the dolphins like
that
you know it is brian flores you know he
knows brian dayball a little bit
all those i'd probably try to knock them
out i don't want to have to play them a
third time and deal with that
we'll take our chances with the ravens
coming into the town i'm i'm more of
that line of thinking as well
last but still least the nfc east
washington
at 17 eagles at 20 giants down to 22
after losing at home to the cardinals
and then there are the cowboys in the
nobody cares
range of the bike at number 27.
uh steve kornacki has that path that he
put together this weekend for the path
to the
nfc east championship washington
currently with the best chance of
winning at all 71
giants at 17 eagles at 11 cowboys
at one percent uh question from pft pm
posse the guy who runs that account is a
cowboys fan do you factor got flexed out
of
prime time slash national time slots
into your power rankings
not not expressly it's just part of the
broader
nobody cares about the cowboys formula
right now
and frankly we went through this earlier
this week when we started to talk about
the outcome of the cowboys bengals game
and all due respect to jerry jones who's
going to do his best to sell his team
and has been great over the last 30 plus
years at selling his team currently
chris
nobody cares no you're right i i could i
could care less
you know as well i mean that was the
least interesting game on the tv last
week
it really was cowboys bengals i mean i
just couldn't have cared less about it
really
uh so they are yeah america's team maybe
but not this year necessarily and
mike i i don't know i mean i'm going to
be really interested to see what goes on
in that nfc east
i really am i mean the one you just look
at that graphic and nicole if you could
throw that up again the the steve
kornacki
uh special there i i mean there's
there's
like still a part of me that i look at
it and just go
man washington could lose to the
seahawks this week we know that
washington can lose to anybody
you know they can we know their offenses
they're offensively challenged
and i mean what if jalen hurts on them
beat the cardinals this week even though
maybe not likely
they certainly could beat the cowboys
next week i mean you really could be
looking at the showdown between the
eagles and washington
uh for for the nfc east when when all
said and done there and that would be
phenomenal but
i mean i would not be shocked i just
think the giant schedule might be too
much to overcome with the browns and
ravens
and i just look at that that match up
and that could be for something there in
week 17.
that's what i'm rooting for i am rooting
for washington philly week 17
nbc prime time now that the browns lost
and it's
going to be a very long shot for the
steelers in the browns game to come down
to
week 17 for the afc north unless the
steelers somehow
lose to the bengals on monday night
football this week right
uh washington philadelphia looks like
the game and frankly if it's not
washington philadelphia i gotta look
around at the
week 17 schedules some more there there
may not be a playoff play in game
usually we can count on one and i think
one year
there wasn't one and we just didn't have
a prime time game
i think you're right remember that that
was just a couple of years ago if there
isn't
one they just don't do it yeah um all
right
uh the cowboys in this week's nobody
cares game play
the 49ers who are at 21. before we wrap
this segment i want to pose these
questions to you
it's a combo from the bat 80 22 and
what the frick man if you're running the
49ers
do you move on from jimmy garoppolo and
if so under what circumstance and then
also part two from what the frick man
what veteran quarterback do you target
if you're the 49ers this offseason
all right well look i i can't say that
i've totally dove into the or
dove into this subject uh to quite
figure out all the particulars there
um i i think let's start with part one
do you think are you obg
or not pass fail yes no well okay i
would say
it it can't be that way you got to have
a plan first to know
okay we have a chance to get this guy or
that guy right
so they gotta you you're not gonna to me
you don't get rid of jimmy g
no first part of my plan i want a guy
who can show up and play every week
it's not too much to ask in the nfl most
starting quarterbacks who are operating
under major contracts
find a way to show up and play every
week and i understand if you can't
physically walk
you can't play the point is having the
awareness in the pocket and outside of
the pocket and everywhere you are the
thing that's still burned into my brain
is that stupid move from a couple of
years ago
on the sideline in kansas city where he
decided to be jimmy tough guy and drop
his shoulder he tears his aco
you got to be smarter than that if you
want to play quarterback week in and
week out in the nfl
you have you owe it to your team for the
money they're paying you
to find a way to stay on the field so
for me the easy part is bye bye jimmy g
i need somebody who can play all 16
weeks then the harder part is who do you
go
well that you know that that's where i'm
saying i just think that has to be done
a little bit
a little bit you can't just throw him to
the side and go okay he doesn't you know
listen he got unlucky first off
you know the referees it's not there's
too much unlucky okay
this year his original injury happened
because
the referee was so worried about his
mask
he didn't blow the whistle and jimmy g
was down
and somebody hit him and then hurt his
ankle i mean
so that's not his fault that's a bunch
of bull crap and like the nfl should pay
him an extra bonus
hey we we screwed up your your season
here you go
but uh you you do have to have i think
some sort of a plan in place to go okay
i know we're gonna get this guy or that
guy to replace him
you can't just go you're out of here and
now let's figure out who we want
you might get stuck at the table going
damn we didn't get anybody or now we
have to go to
the draft and get a rookie quarterback
but i i think it's
it's certainly in up in the air as far
as moving on for jimmy g
and i would just think shanahan this
year after seeing like russell wilson
and rogers and kyler murray and then
what josh allen did to his football team
at some point i would think he'd go man
i need to get me one of these one of
these guys that
you know gets me out of jail free card
when my offense isn't kicking butt and
can make things happen
and he really hasn't had that and uh
that's where
i think it's going to be a an
interesting debate or conversation
isn't that we're way over but i i'm
fascinated by this because i think
that's the fundamental tension in the
shanahan offense
his desire to have a guy who is
basically
the madden character as he works the
controller
from all of the predetermined moves
right right versus the guy who's gonna
say screw it this isn't gonna work
i'm gonna go do my own thing because the
last thing kyle shanahan wants is a guy
who's gonna freelance it's a balance
but at some point i think you have to
welcome that ability to make chicken
salad on the fly because it will get you
out of a bad boy right
i agree i think so too yeah you know
right he might freelance every now and
then
and you you know oh man shanahan
delivered you an open guy and it didn't
work out but i think in the long run
those guys we're talking about make a
lot more positives than they do
of the negative aspect of what you were
saying there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports